I've asked you guys this question for at
least 17 years and I'm gonna ask it
again you guys have the rights to the
raid or do you not have the rights for
them no we do we well well well
here's we had the rights to our version
are we sure we have we own the script
yeah the script that we wrote that we
have that our script is way cool it's
our script and we parted ways with X Y Z
who owns the title but not the script we
own the script and we are right now
negotiating with it's pretty sexy right
yeah with a big name you know we have
another name that we love that's gonna
play who's gonna play the bad guy
and so we're assembling this movie to be
we're going to do a movie called Leo
from Toledo with another Mel Gibson
movie myself and there we go yeah Joe's
gonna direct and then hopefully our
movie which is not called the raid but
it's the same script will be after that
guys this is clarification the the
version that I wrote they don't ever
intend to actually go in they think that
they're gonna move this guy so their
whole operation is we're gonna hit this
guy in transit and it's not until he
realized oh they're digging in they're
not they're not moving we've got an
outgoing again for those who know the
ring for those those that know the rate
it's a very very different script yeah
the bones of it the bones there's a
similar story inside of it but but but
it's really really really about the
brother it's about the tube it's not
it's not it's me and Brad Pitt anyway
I'm obsessed now with Brad Pitt I don't
know but Frank goes blonde which is
really really something to see I'll go
blonde for Brad Pitt do you guys have a
new title for this script it's called
Brad Pitt Brad Pitt it's actually Brad
Pitt's rade that's that's we're call
rating Brad Pitt
is Brad here thank you I actually do
love practice just does it have a title
are you figuring in a casino that's
what's called which is the character's
name told Zeena's you know that's that's
that's the main characters ex z en oh I
don't can't spell it so you can't know
you really sold Z no listen no that's
what's called Raven drinking I do a
movie both out I'm joking
nope spelling in me or not the good
friends